MARK MIRCHANDANI: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Next 2019 showcase
floor.
NATALIE PIUCCO: We're
super excited to take you
around all the different
demo areas and neighborhoods
that we have around the floor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
lots of cool stuff down there.
So why don't we show you around?
[UPBEAT ELECTRO MUSIC]
There's much great stuff here
at Google Cloud Next 2019.
We've only begun to scratch
the surface with the showcases
we've shown you.
And there's tons of people
here with high energy.
NATALIE PIUCCO: I know, right.
I think there's roughly
around 30,000 people or more
here actually.
Lots of amazing
demo stations where
you can learn about our
Google Cloud Platform.